it's March the 17th in 1873 we're
visiting ancient Rome to watch The
Liberator an annual festival that
celebrates the liberty of Rome's
citizens we're looking in at a 17-year
old named Lucius Papa Dias secundus he's
not from a poor family but he lives in
the region known as the Saburo a poorer
neighborhood in Rome yet close to the
center of the city
the tenants of these apartments are
crammed in which poses considerable risk
fires are frequent and the smell of ash
and smoke in the morning is not uncommon
lucious
who awoke at dawn has family duties to
perform to death his 15 year old brother
is coming of age half the children in
ancient Rome die before they reach
adulthood so this is a particularly
important milestone
Lucius watches his brother stand at his
new toga before the household shrine
with its protective deities as he places
his bulla a protective amulet in the
shrine with a prayer of thanks the bulla
had worked it had protected him unlike
many others he had survived to become an
adult at 17 Lucius has almost completed
his education he has learned to speak
well and make public speeches and how to
read and write both Latin and Greek his
father has taught him the types of
things you can't learn in the classroom
how to run how to swim
Lucius could choose at 70 to become a
military cookie and command soldiers on
the edge of the Empire but in other
words Lucius is still a child he's not
trusted to arrange business deals his
father will take care of that until he
is 25 and dad will arrange Lucius his
marriage to a girl 10 years younger
his dad has his eye on a family with a
seven-year-old daughter back to the
liver alia as Lucia sleeves with his
family the shops are open as the
population goes about its business the
streets are full of itinerant traders
selling trinkets and people bustling
from place to place
large wagons are not allowed in the city
until after the ninth hour but the
streets are still crowded fathers and
uncles take the kids to the forum of
Augustus to see statues of Rome's
famous warriors like Aeneas who led
Rome's ancestors the Trojans to Italy
and Romulus Rome's founder and all the
great generals the Republic from more
than a hundred years earlier lovingly we
can imagine father's and guardians with
their now adult children remembering
stories of Rome's glory and retelling
the good deeds and sayings of the great
men of the past lessons on how to live
well and to overcome the follies of
youth there is a sense of history in
this place relevant to their present
Romans made an empire without end in
time and space
Rome was destined to be eternal through
warfare wars were a fact of life even in
AD 73 there are campaigns in the north
of England and into Scotland to the
north of the river Danube into Romania
and on the frontier between Syria and
Iraq the ether it's now the eighth power
time to head for the baths
Lucius and his family head up the via
lauter the widescreen to the Campus
Martius and the enormous baths of
Agrippa the family members leave the
clients and freedmen outside and enter
the baths with their peer group bars
have changed from dark steamy rooms to
light ones the Romans have perfected
window gloves everyone moves from the
cold room to the tepid room into the
very hot more than an hour later the
bathers leave massaged oiled and have
been scraped down with astragal to
remove the remaining dirt at the ninth
hour seven hours after they left home
the men returned for a celebratory
dinner dinner is an intimate affair with
nine people reclining around the low
table slaves attempt their every need of
the diners through gestures demand more
food and wine as the day closes we can
hear the rumble of wagons outside the
clients and Freedman with a meal of
robust if inferior food inside them
shuffle off to the now tepid baths
before returning to their apartment
blocks back at lucious's house the
drinking continues into the night
Lucius and his stepbrother don't look
too well a slave stand by
in case either of them needs to vomit
with hindsight we know lucious's future
in twenty years time the Emperor
Vespasian's youngest son Domitian as
Emperor will enact a reign of terror
will lucious survive